katia bonjour alors jusqu ici rien n'est
officiel mais quelles sont les
informations qui circulent en ce moment
au sujet du remaniement
oui en effet il ya des bruits de couloir
avec certains auquel on peut vraiment
apporter plus de crédit que d'autres
alors d'ores et déjà on sait ça c'est
une certitude que le gouvernement
devrait compter 20 ministres et
ministres délégués c'est à peu près la
même chose qu'aujourd'hui puisque il y
actuellement seize ministres et trois
ministres délégués peu de ministres
devraient également rester en place
là on parle de florence parly aux armées
qui se situe de rester ainsi que
jean-yves le drian aux affaires
étrangères mais concernant le ministre
de la transition écologique
on a longuement évoqué le nom de jean
louis borloo
mais finalement ce serait plutôt une
autre personne qui fait actuellement
partie des kits gouvernementales et
quitter une ancienne une ancienne membre
d'europe écologie les verts barbra
pompili pour ne pas la nommer
concernant le ministère de la culture il
pourrait s'agir de grozine bachelot
alors ça reste encore évidemment qu'une
rumeur pour remplacer franck riester qui
sur rai qui serait sur le départ
d'autres noms ont été annoncés mais bon
je pense qu'il faut pas trop donné dans
la rumeur si ce n'est que de parler que
du poste de christophe castaner on sait
qu'il est très contesté depuis des
semaines une fronde policière est à ses
trousses en revanche il faudrait choisir
un nouveau ministre mais lequel pourrait
convenir aux policiers les syndicats
sont très attentifs à cela et bien
justement pour aller dans leur sens jean
castex nouveau premier ministre est allé
faire une visite surprise la caserne de
la courneuve
hier et il a prévenu les policiers qu'il
ferait une suggestion au président pour
un nouveau ministre de l'intérieur donc
voici pour les premières rumeurs et on
attend leur confirmation dans quelques
heures
merci katia 26 en direct un aux abords
du palais
l'élysée on vous retrouve lors de nos
prochaines éditions